What is Maladaptive Daydreaming?
Have you ever sat through a boring class?
Only to find yourself drifting into a daydream?
Maybe you have dreamt about laying in paradise,
Minutes before checking out of a shift
In most cases,
We daydream when we wish to be elsewhere
but can't change the current setting or situation just yet.
It sounds harmless, creative, and fun right?
But too much of anything is always bad for you.
Here's what you need to know about maladaptive daydreaming
What is it?
Maladaptive daydreaming is a term first coined by Professor Eli Somer.
It is a psychiatric phenomenon that can interfere
with you ability to carry out daily tasks
including your academics, work, and other regular activities.
Professor Somer found that maladaptive day dreaming occurs in people's lives that have suffered from severe trauma.
As a result, they would daydream in order to escape their harsh painful realities.
What's interesting about maladaptive daydreaming is that it actually isn't represented in the DSM handbook
that psychologists often refer to when diagnosing patients.
However, some professionals believe it is a mental disorder that can severely affect the individual.
What are the symptoms?
People who experience maladaptive daydreaming
often get triggered  by real life traumatizing events or mere reminders of them.
They usually have very vivid detailed daydreams that contain rich, imaginative plots.
You might whisper during these daydreams
which can last for hours and effect your ability to finish tasks.
You might have trouble sleeping at night too.
Maladaptive daydreaming can also coexist with
other psychiatric problems including ADD, OCD, and depression.
Is there treatment for it?
Unfortunately, there is no known treatment for maladaptive daydreaming.
However there are techniques you can use
to reduce the symptoms such as avoiding potentially triggering people, places, and situations.
There is also medication one can take to manage their daydreams.
Although maladaptive daydreaming cannot be diagnosed yet by professionals
we want to approach it with an open mind,
and enjoyed exploring it with you.
We also included a helpful resource provided in the description box
for anyone who maybe struggling with daydreaming.
What other interesting facts do you know about maladaptive daydreaming?
Share your thoughts with us below,
also please be sure to subscribe to our channel
for more helpful tips.
and share this video with others,
with your help we can reach more people to spread awareness.
on the mind and mental health issues.
Thanks for watching.